have you beaten Zelda breath of the wild
and if you have how long did it take you
well whatever your answer is it's likely
that you took longer to complete less of
the game then speedrunners aleca who
recently ran one heck of a gauntlet I'm
Matt and this is your speedrunning game
spot news update zakka completed a 100%
speed run in breadth of the wild and it
only took him 49 hours 9 minutes and 41
seconds in that time he collected all
900 Korac seeds completed all 120
shrines finished every single quest and
more the full requirements for a 100%
speed run are demanding and even asks
you to complete the compendium which
means you have to take a photo of every
item and enemy in the game that's a
pretty dang tall order for people who
are taking things at their own pace
anyway if you want more interesting
Zelda coverage then make sure to LIKE
and subscribe to be the first to watch
all of our awesome features and stories
Zella cos time may be impressive but he
thinks he can do better
he believes that without exploiting any
major glitches the 100% speed-run could
be done in about 35 hours he says at his
next attempt will try to get closer to
that goal with a sub 40 hour completion
time we'll have to wait and see how he
does but in the meantime check out our
latest breath of the wild live stream in
which we try to beat even tide island
with nothing but the sheikah Slade's
powers
[Music]
Oh